パパパパ
ふぅ～
ああ
動画撮らないとね
パパパパ
あーー
こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
今日人間ドッグに行ってきました
去年
人間ドックに行って
あの～それから毎年、ちょっとちゃんと
受けようかなっていうことで
今年も人間ドックに行ってきました
はあぁぁぁ～～～～
づっ
ぅうううんうぅ～～うっうっう
づつ　ずっ
はい
すいません
健康診断より
もっとこう、細かいんですよね
人間ドック
身長とか体重とかなんか視力とかじゃ
なくて
もっとその
血とか心電図とかね
バリウム飲んで
なんかぐるぐるぐるってされたり
ホントいろんな事が
人間ドックで分かるんで
とんでもなく不規則でめちゃくちゃな生活してるんで
もう早期発見が何よりもいいんで
ちょっとちゃんと人間ドック
受けようかなということで今年も
行ってきたんですけども
去年受けた時と
大きく違うことが一 つ ございまして
それは何かと言いますと
お肉を食べていない
そう
もう4月なんでお肉禁止してから
約3ヶ月が経ちました
お肉禁止します動画の
コメント欄皆さん見ましたでしょうか
何人もの人が!!!　何人もの人が!!!!
( ﾟДﾟ)＜お前やめとけ!!　危険だ!!＞(‘Д`)
(*_*;＜まじで危ないと思います、やめてください
たくさんの人からあぶなあぶないと言われて
ほんっとにぃ
怖かったです
死ぬ死ぬとか言われたら
僕は死ぬんじゃねぇかなとか思ってちょっと怖かったんですけど
それも含めてなんか健康診断で
その管理栄養士の方とかいたんでその人に
あの僕お肉禁止するんですけど大丈夫でしょうか
( ﾟДﾟ)ﾊｯ?
みたいな感じでちょっと聞いてみたり
したのでちょっと色々まとめ て
今回発表していきたいと思います
すうすすううううううううはあああああああああ
ズバリ、結果から言いますと
ズツ（悲）
めっちゃ良くなりましたああぁぁぁ!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
YEAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAY
(効果音)
いや、まじですごいっすよ
あの結果から言いますと
超
健康になりました
これはもう数値を見れば一目瞭然です
ちょっといろいろ発表していきますよ
身長が変わらず186cm
体重が、去年が
65.6kg今年が
68kg
ちょっと増えましたね
ちなみに僕の標準体重は75,9kgです
まだまだ大丈夫ですね
で、肥満度が前回が
-13% 今年 が マイナス 10.4%
まだまだ
痩せてます
ということです
安心した!
体脂肪率、14%から23%が基準らしいんですんですけど
えーっと僕は、13.2%でした
体重だけで言うと2.4kgぐらい去年から
比べて太ったなーくらいでございます
平均より全然痩せ方だったんでむしろ太って
何か良いよみたいな感じでした
あざす！！
健康診断して中性脂肪みたら
すっごい悪くてそれでなんか原因をたどると
多分ラーメンの食い過ぎだろうなっていうことで、去年ラーメン
1年禁止したんですけども
こちらですね前回から見ていきましょう
去年が
えーーっ
総コレステロール
基準値が140から219で
227!!!
これ赤字になってるのがちょっと危ないです
っていうやつでございます
中性脂肪
よく聞きますよね
40から149 だったらまぁ基準値らしいですけども
去年なんと
180!!!
ぅうぇぁぁぁっ!!!!!
いやよくないんですよ
本当に
これ見て僕まじでちょっとお医者さんに
中性脂肪高すぎて危ないですよ
って言われて
こちらが今年の結果です
どうぞ
キラリ～ン☆
はっ!!はっ!!はっ!!はっ!!はっ!!はっ!!はっ!!はっ!!
見ろぉ
中性脂肪
77だぁ―――!!!!!!!!
やばくないですか
去年
180だったのがこっち
77まで落としましたした
そしてご覧下さい
去年、赤字が3つあったやつが今、
赤字がありませんっ!!!!!!
ウェイ!!!!
全て
異常なしでございます!!
良かった
まじでよかった
ありがとうございます
もうなんか問診表に
本当にお肉禁止してるのちょっと怖くて
書いたんですよ
お肉食べなくて心配ですって書いて
で色々聞いたんですけど
やっぱ全然ありらしいですよ
お肉禁止
去年に比べ てはるかに体が良くなっ ている
素晴らしい
と、お褒めのお言葉をいただきました
ありがとうございます
あ、全然僕いまラーメンとか食ってるんすよ
全然ラーメンとか食ってるんですけども
それ以外のお肉禁止することによって
揚げ物とか脂っぽいのが全く食わなくなって
おそらくそういうところで中性脂肪が結構
もう半分以下にグワッと
落ちたのではないかなということでございます
お肉禁止は本当に危ないです
やめた方がいいですと言っていた皆様
ざまぁみやがれぇ!!!!!!
一つ言われたのはやっぱお肉禁止することによって
お肉食べないと取り入れられない
栄養素があるからそこだけ気をつけてください
ということを言われました
でなんでちゃんと意識的にタンパク質とか
卵とか大豆とか
お肉のちゃんと代わりになるものがあるのでそこ
をちゃんと食べてれば、全く
問題ないという感じでございました
これでなんかお肉禁止しますつって体壊したら
マジでダサいなと思ってたんで
よかったお肉禁止がすべての原因ではないと
思うんですけど
間違いなく去年と比べて体が
健康になっております
まだ3ヶ月しかしてませんからね
それでこんだけ変わるってことはこれ
お肉禁止してして良かったんじゃね？
て思える日がが9 カ月後にくるように祈りたいと思います
残り9か月間頑張るぞぉ!!!!!!!!!!!
END